اسمح لينوه على هذا الخبر العاجل الذي
نشاهده على شاشتنا سرايا القدس تنعي عضو
المجلس العسكري ومسؤول وحده العمليات اياد
الحسني الذي استشهد في غاره اسرائيليه في
قطاع غزه اذا كان هناك استهداف
لمبنى سكني استهداف اسرائيل عندما عدت
اليك اوائل اذا في القطاع
الان اذا
تعلن سرايا القدس عن هويه
الشهيد في ذلك المبنى الذي استهدف
اسرائيليا وتقول انه عضو المجلس العسكري
ومسؤول وحده العمليات اياد الحسن
[موسيقى]
هذا صحيح اذا الاسم الذي اعلنته اسرائيل
واعلنت انها استهدفته في الشقه السكنيه في
منطقه حي النصر هو نفس الاسم الذي اعلنت
عنه سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي وقالت بانه عضو المجلس
العسكري ومسؤول وحده العمليات في سرايا
القدس الذي ارتقى في عمليه الاغتيال
الصهيونيه مساء هذا اليوم
الحديث للبيان الذي صدرته سرايا القدس وهو
بيان
مقتضب ولم يحتوي على كثير من المعلومات
سوى الاسم والمهمه او المنصب الذي يشغله
اياد الحسني وايضا لم ياتي على ذكر الشخص
الاخر او الشهيد الاخر الذي اخلي من نفس
الشقه وكان
عندما استهدفت هذه الشقه بينما كان يتواجد
الحسني في هذا في الشقه السكنيه المستهدفه